[Musique]
cette affaire fait grincer des dents car
elle est accablante tout est parti en
fait d'un groupe de parlementaires qui
ont rapporté aux autorités des faits d'
usage de drogue et d odeur de cannabis
dans les couloirs de westminster ralph
l'effondrement meurtrier d'un immeuble à
sanary sur mer dans le var un jeune
homme de 30 ans a été retrouvé mort dans
les décombres
au moins six personnes dont un bébé pour
pu être sauvés les policiers ont
retrouvé des traces de cocaïne dans onze
toilettes notamment une qui est juste à
côté du bureau du premier ministre boris
johnson lui même et des équipes
spécialisées deux pompiers sont toujours
à la recherche de deux personnes
une dame âgée de 70 ans et son fils
handicapé de 45 ans il habitait au
premier étage de cet immeuble le
gouvernement de joe biden et les
officiels américains ne se rendront pas
aux jeux olympiques et paralympiques de
pékin en 2022 en raison des génocide et
des crimes en cours auxinjiang et pour
lutter contre le non-respect des droits
de l'homme évidemment je drague personne
je dis juste que
le résultat du second tour de la
primaire des républicains montrent que
chez l air en tout cas il ya 60% de
mondialiser 40% de patriotes le mensonge
du siècle fabriqué par les états unis
sur le prétendu génocide et xu zhong est
depuis longtemps démasqué par les faits
la tentative des états unis d'interférer
avec les jeux olympiques d'hiver de
pékin par préjugé idéologique sur la
base de mensonges et de rumeurs ne fera
que révéler les sinistres attention de
la partie américaine via des gens qui
viennent pour faire de la provocation
ils viennent ils savent très bien qu'ils
vont énervé les gens qui sont là ils le
font pour ça et ils le font pour que les
médias disent ouhlala ils sont méchants
les autres sont violents il n'avait rien
à faire là il réussit à s'en prendre aux
juges aux journalistes aux féministes
aux gays et aux lesbiennes aux
enseignants
aux anti raciste violemment pendant son
métissé pas libye non vous les aimez
mais ce climat
et le pire climat que l'on pourrait
promettre à la france pour fait vous
êtes de mèche avec lui vous vous lui
avez dit prends soin la première cible
et moi je suis en je suis en recul en
réalité toutes les comparaisons
si vous voulez c'est vrai que
l'émergence d' avec ces mots à peut-être
réussi à montrer aux français que le
projet qui était le nôtre était un
projet en même temps raisonnable
rigoureux rien donner des leçons quand
on est assis dans son canapé dans le
rôle du commentateur c'est beaucoup plus
difficile beaucoup plus facile quand on
rentre sur le terrain ce site c'est une
évidence il est le grand vide il est là
si vous voulez hein c'est un adolescent
qui se cherche on a l'impression d'un
type qui n'est pas fini on a
l'impression de quelqu'un qui n'a pas en
fait les idées claires sur rien c'est
des propos qui n'appellent objectivement
pas de réponse on voit bien que eric
zemmour manille en permanence les
insultes invectives ce type n'est pas
fini ce type dit tout et le contraire de
tout donc moi je dis oui emmanuel macron
c'est le vide et c'est un adolescent qui
n'est pas fini
monsieur zemmour
il faut apaiser tout ça ça fait voilà et
bon jeu pourtant dans les toilettes pour
non mais je pense qu'il faut
c'est
il faut prendre de la hauteur
maître du calme le pays a besoin
d'ambition cette bienveillance on voit
qu'il ya besoin un peu de voir à qui a
besoin de sensationnel qu'il ya besoin
pour vous de divertir quand même
l'opinion donc à hull moment zemmour
septembre octobre novembre vous avez dit
zemmour c'est la superstar maintenant
c'est pécresse voilà maintenant c'est
pécresse emmanuel macron est donnée
battue au deuxième tour sondages et lab
pour bfm 52% pour valérie pécresse 48 48
pour sa part emmanuel macron